whenever we talk about money the amount
of money is not the only thing that
matters what also matters is when you
have to get or when you have to give the
money so to think about this or to make
it a little bit more concrete let's
assume that we live in a world that if
you put money in a bank you are
guaranteed ten percent Interest ten
percent risk risk free interest in a
bank and this is high by historical
standards but it'll make our math easy
so let's just assume that you can always
get ten percent risk-free interest in
the bank now given that let me throw out
scenarios and have you think about which
of these that you would most want so I
could give you $100 right now that's
option one I could in one year instead
of giving you the hundred dollars
immediately in one year I could give you
I could give you one hundred and nine
dollars and then in two years in two
years this is kind of option three I'd
be willing to give you one hundred one
hundred and twenty dollars so your
choice is someone walks up you up to the
street I can give you a hundred dollar
bill now one hundred nine dollar bill it
$109 one hundred nine dollars in a year
or 120 dollars two years from now and
you know in the back of your mind you
can get 10% risk-free interest so given
that you don't have an immediate need
for money you're assuming that this
money you will save that you don't have
to you know that you don't have a bill
to pay immediately which of these things
are the most desirable which of these
would you most want to have well if you
just cared about the absolute value or
the absolute amount of the money you
would say hey look $120 that's the
biggest amount of money I'm going to
take that one because that's just the
biggest number but you probably have in
the back of your mind well they I'm
getting that later so there's maybe
something I'm losing out there and you'd
be right you'd be losing out on the
opportunity to get the ten percent
risk-free interest if you were to get
the money earlier and if you want to if
you wanted to compare them directly the
thought process would be well let's see
if I got if I took option
one if i got the hundred dollars and if
you were to put it in the bank what
would that grow what would that grow to
based on that ten percent risk-free
interest well after one year ten percent
of a hundred dollars is ten dollars so
you would get ten dollars in interest so
after one year your entire savings in
the bank will now be one hundred and ten
dollars so just doing that little
exercise we actually see that a hundred
dollars given now put it in the bank at
ten percent of risk free will actually
turn into one hundred ten dollars a year
from now which is better than the
hundred and nine dollars one year from
now so given this scenario or given this
kind of situation or this option you
would rather do this then do this your
better a year from now you're better off
by a dollar what about two years from
now well if you take that hundred
dollars after one year it becomes one
hundred ten dollars then ten percent of
110 is eleven dollars is $11 so you want
to add eleven dollars to it and so it
becomes it becomes one hundred and
twenty one dollars so once again you're
better off taking the hundred dollars
investing it in the bank risk-free ten
percent per year it turns into one
hundred and twenty one dollars that is a
better situation than just someone
guaranteeing you to give the one hundred
twenty dollars in two years once again
you are better off by a dollar and so
this idea that not just the amount
matters but when you get it this idea is
called the time value of money time time
value of money or another way to think
about it is think about what the value
of this money is over time given some
expected interest rate and when you do
that you can compare this money to equal
amounts of money at some future date now
another way of thinking about the time
value or I guess another related concept
to the time value of money is the idea
of present value present present value
and maybe I'll talk about present and
future value so present present and
future value future value
so given this assumption this 110 this
10 percent assumption
if I if someone to ask you what is the
present value of a hundred and twenty
one dollars two years in the future you
would that's they're essentially asking
you so let's so what is the present
value so the present PV stands for
present value so what is the present
value of one hundred twenty one dollars
two years in the future that's
equivalent to asking what type of money
or what amount of money would you have
to put in the bank risk-free over the
next two years to get one hundred twenty
one dollars and we know that if you put
a hundred dollars in the bank for two
years at ten percent risk-free you would
get one hundred and twenty one dollars
so the present value here the present
value of one hundred and twenty one
dollars is the hundred dollars or
another way to think about present and
future value if someone were to ask what
is the future value so what is the
future value of this hundred dollars in
one year so in one year well if you put
if you get ten percent of the bank
that's guaranteed its future value is
100 to ten dollars after two years it's
two year future value is one hundred and
twenty one dollars and so with that in
mind let me give you one slightly more
interesting problem so let's say that I
have let's say we're going to assume
this the whole time that makes our math
easy a 10 percent risk-free interest and
let's say that someone says that they're
willing to give us they're willing to
give us sixty five dollars in one year
and we were to ask ourselves what is the
present value of this so what is the
present value what is the present value
of this so remember the present value is
just asking you what a mount of money
that if you were to put it in the bank
at this risk-free interest would be
equivalent to this sixty five dollars
which of these two are equivalent to you
and so you would say well look whatever
amount of money that is let's call that
X whatever amount of money that is x if
I grow it by ten percent that's
literally I'm taking X plus ten percent
x plus let me write it this way plus ten
percent times X
let me write not let me make it clear
this way X X plus 10% of X should be
equal to our $65 if I take if I take the
amount I get 10% of that amount over the
near that should be equal to $65 and
this is the same thing as 1 X or we
could say that 1 X plus 10% is the same
thing as 0.1 0 X is equal to 65 or you
add these two 1.10 X is equal to 65 and
if you want to solve for the actual
amount of the present value here you
would just divide both sides by the 1.10
and so you get X is equal to let me let
me do it this way be a little bit more
clear about it so let's divide both
sides by 1 point and really that
trailing zero doesn't matter we're not
really too worried about the precision
here because this isn't this is actually
exactly 10% so this is going to be these
cancel out and X is going to be equal to
we get the calculator out X is going to
be equal to 65 divided by 1.1 $59.09
rounding it so X X is equal to $59.09
which was the present value of $65 in
one year or another way to think about
it is if you wanted to know what the
future value of $59.09 is in one year
assuming that 10% interest you would get
$65